there's a guy called stephen jackson
right he's an nba player i don't know if
you're not a big sports fan we can pull
up this guy
he's got a podcast called all the smoke
how much you smoke you want
i want all the smoke i want all the
smoke i want all of it anyways
here's the story
former nba player now all the smoke
podcaster stephen jackson he says he
walked off the out the altar the day of
his wedding
after his fiancee or his bride-to-be at
the time refused to sign the prenup get
out and then
and then that night
he banged one of her bridesmaids
it
oh yeah yeah no steven jackson
no yeah yeah get into this story so
here's here's a little save that money
story for you right there ladies and
gentlemen
so jackson you know all the smoke
podcasts there is he played 14 seasons
the nba made about 70 million million
million dollars he was a decent player
he was a i don't think he was ever an
all-star but he was a he was a good good
role player
uh played with spurs played golden state
a little game so basically back in the
day early 2010s i want to say yeah he
was engaged to what is now
this la
basketball wives star
her name is imani showalter
but he refused to get married to her
unless she signed a prenup okay cool bro
so recently he tells a story like
they're like dude what happened on your
wedding right he had nba players there
he had celebrities there you know how
nba guys do they're doing their thing he
tells the story he said he's he spent
400 grand for this wedding like you
should have spent that on the down
payment of the house yeah bingo 400
grand on a wedding then at the last
second they called off get a load of
this story
he says she was dragging her feet on the
prenup wouldn't do it she was making up
excuses they weren't adding up
basically he wakes up on the wedding day
anxiety riddled oh my god what's
happening i'm not sure
prenup still unsigned she's still not
sure what she's going to do they're
getting ready there's bridesmaids are
getting ready freaking bobby van tin
bobby valentino you know crooner r b guy
he's singing he's got the pastor coming
in there he's a pastor
and finally like the moment of truth
when it's ready to walk down the aisle
she just didn't sign the prenup homie
goes no
i'm out
she revealed her true colors called it
off
let's see a picture of this called it
off there he is yeah called off the
wedding night go back to the article
and then he says this he tells this
whole story and then and then he drops
then he drops like the the other the
other foot on he goes yeah on the
wedding night the wedding night that
didn't happen i spent all this money as
did all this thing i still was gonna
party you know we
we obviously didn't get married
so we partied uh at the hotel
you know where they were all we're all
getting down and he says quote unquote
me and the partners were getting ready
to go out
the partners
two of her oh main squeezes that was
with her dude they were with us at night
you know wedding festivities
and he goes yeah i'm gonna keep it funky
i'm gonna keep it real
funky
i downed one of them
no
i think that's code word for i bagged
one of them i downed i downed one of
them that i don't think it's a new one
yeah it's a new one
uh i don't think that's the classiest
approach but he engaged in physical
intercourse with one of them yeah uh you
feel me yeah and he goes but that's her
friends though he goes those are that's
how she rolls dude those are her friends
that's your brother and yeah and he goes
yeah i did i banged one of her friends
there it was because if i'm going to
spend 400 grand at a wedding i'm gonna
get something back
that's that roi you're talking about
right now why
dude that is scummy yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah right you didn't get married
yeah but you were supposed to feeling
salty
who's worse in that situation stephen
jackson of the bridesmaid who is wrong
in that situation there it's all sorts
of wrongs it's all wrong
i'll tell you who's not wrong the guy
who spent 400 grand that he wanted to
get married
that
the girl didn't want to walk down the
aisle for the prenup
he's like it's my wedding night i'm
having sex with somebody
that's who it is anyway i see a lot of
laughing emojis that's what's going on
the life and times of stephen jackson
um what would you have done in that
situation i wouldn't have walked down
the aisle without the prenup homie could
be he made 70 million dollars he could
be giving up 35 million dollars half his
so because home girl wouldn't sign
the premium exactly so he didn't walk
down the aisle yeah oh okay good okay
right she didn't sign the burrito so i'm
not dude i agree man at that at
that level like ah no it's like no no no
this is weird like why don't you want to
sign it that badly
like that's what i would be thinking
like yeah why don't you just do it
obviously the relationship so um yeah
the relationship i would say did not
work out
look i i was married briefly yeah i
don't know if you know this i got a
prenup uh it was in my party phase i was
in my early 30s i was starting to make
money fell in love with a girl um
there may or may not have been some
paperwork issues involved because she
was british anyway we got married real
quickly i said listen before we get
married yeah sweetheart i love you we're
together
i'm gonna need you to sign to this
prenup is that how you said it yeah and
you know what she said
yeah okay
sign the prenup see that's see then that
that's someone that's like i have no
intention of taking your money dude what
do you want do you want me to sign back
yes yeah you want me to sign and anyway
we the relationship it was ups downs
left right we had a good time we weren't
meant to be forever but
the point is this i was in love we were
crazy we were in our south beach party
days
you know a long way from there
but i was like holy i've got some
money now this girl does not have money
i know we're in love but we got a whole
sorts of things going on
i'm gonna get a prenup signed yeah good
for you okay
and um
when
five years later the relationship was up
down left to right and finally we called
it quits
that's it we
amicably there was no issues we had no
kids
you know there was no child support
there was no who's getting what it went
down very easily and look i don't know
the girl but i feel just right off of
her reaction of okay
even if you hadn't signed one no
intention of signing it but then someone
who hesitates dude you okay now you
definitely have to sign it because
you're 100 taking my money well look i'm
not saying that that that you know
i'm not this prenup expert but
this is something a conversation you
should have before you get married yeah
totally and what it is like you said
like you were joking you're like i'm
broke as yeah but if i marry a rich
girl i don't want to sign a bruno if i
want that you want half her
exactly yeah that's the mindset anyway i
have a business partner of mine
he got married to a girl
good they had no money when they got
married he was just starting his career
they both were starting from scratch
they were in their 20s they fell in love
no prenup
homie ends up doing very well for
himself he was making a lot of money
yeah he was he was
and
um i think i don't know how much he was
making a year just
well well well into six figures you know
half a million bucks maybe a million bug
he was doing very well oh this is an
awkward conversation yeah uh
got divorced
oh you get divorced
um she
you know went after
everything or whatever
of course he was paying her 10 000
a month
a month she was getting paid 120 grand a
year to do nothing now they raise kids
there's families of respect i'll get it
you think he's happy no you think
because what they do is apparently they
take i think like their your last
three years of salary average it up so
if you're doing really well
not a good time to get that i don't know
there's so many angles with that
yeah of course like she supported him
while he was making money and then you
gotta do it for seven years ten years
however long i think however long you've
been married they cut it in half if
you're married 20 years that's 10 years
it's not fun
[Music]
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broke
[Music]